hello everyone
uh welcome
welcome to nudging big buyers towards
greener products the third installment
of the colloquium on sustainable
marketing series sponsored by decrea
this series aims to unravel and address
the challenges of creating
environmentally sustainable products
services and brands that customers love
today's discussion will cover how
retailers and suppliers
can work together to sell greener
products
how they effectively market those
products to consumers
and
and how they can use marketing to nudge
big buyers towards more
environmentally sustainable
products we are privileged to have
representatives from two of the leading
green product retailers dell and office
depot
to explore these issues and others
before introducing our panel we would
like to thank the yale center for
business and the environment yale center
for customer insights um for making the
colloquium unsustainable marketing
possible
we'd also like to thank
sustainable brands for their help from
promoting the event
and now a quick introduction to our
speakers
yamas siddiqui is senior director of
environmental strategy at office depot
under his leadership office depot was
ranked america's number one greenest
large retailer in 2010 2011 and 2012 by
newsweek magazine
yamas is on the board of the national
advisory council on environmental policy
and technology
a council that provides strategic advice
to the epa
administrator
he is co-chair of the sustainable
purchasing leadership council
and is the only private sector recipient
of the responsible purchasing network's
responsible purchaser of the year award
yamas has a masters in environmental or
environment and development
from cambridge and a bachelor of
commerce from mcgill
i had the opportunity to work with yamas
at office depot this past summer
through the edf climate corps program
and i was most blown away by his
effectiveness
in engaging stakeholders from different
departments and organizations to come
together for environmental purposes
next we have michael murphy
he's the executive director
of worldwide regulatory compliance
engineering and environmental affairs at
dell incorporated
michael is responsible for leading
global technical regulations and
standards engagement design for
environment programs
governing environmental regulatory
compliance of all dell solutions
and increasing dell sustainable product
sustainable product and packaging
leadership across its
portfolio he is one of the primary
authors of dell's annual corporate
sustainability or corporate
responsibility report and regularly
engages
sorry regularly engages customers on the
sustainability value proposition
of information communications technology
he holds and holds or manages various
board memberships with the sustainable
consortium
ep among others
finally our moderator is dr anastasia
o'rourke principal with decra
sustainability here in new haven
she has over 15 years experience in the
field of corporate government and ngo
sustainability with clients such as the
u.s general services administration epa
coca-cola europe the carbon trust and
sustainability consortium
holding a master of science from london
university in sweden
and a phd from here at yale
anastasia also serves as co-chair for
the sustainable purchasing leadership
council with yamas
with that anastasia the floor is yours
thank you and thank you so much for
joining us on this really pleasant day
in new haven it's the first
winter storm i think of the season and
uh yeah it was fun getting here and so
thank you for coming out
um what we're gonna do today is have a
sort of
dialogue if you like around marketing
sustainable products uh from the
retailer perspective and from a supplier
perspective
and we called it nudging big buyers
because both of these organizations
largely sell to
commercial
and large institutional purchases so we
thought it's an interesting uh slightly
different arena to talk about
sustainable sustainability marketing of
products than to end consumers like your
uri
um
so i have some questions and then about
halfway through i'm going to open it up
to the floor um so happy to take your
questions and we'll have some questions
from our online audience i hope and uh
let's have a great session today so
thanks for coming both of you thank you
thank you so just to set the context
i think it'd be great for all of us to
hear a bit more about your companies
your sustainability initiatives within
the companies
who are your big buyers uh who do you
who are your customers um michael please
start
so dell you may not be familiar with
we're the world's largest startup as of
october 20th or so
so
after many years of being a private
company we've gone private um that
hasn't changed our commitment though to
corporate social responsibility and
responsibility for our customers
we're a 57 billion dollar revenue
company
global
we operate in 78 countries but we
service about 212 markets globally
our products are aimed at certainly
public large enterprise
commercial accounts but we also have a
product portfolio aimed at
consumers
dell's historically been known more as a
pc company we've been transforming as uh
as a company for several years and part
of that's led to our privatization
really aimed at uh
services solutions and software
but
unlike some of our competitors
transformations i mean we have no
intention of jettisoning hardware from
our portfolio we think it's a
conversation starter
with many of our current customers
but
57 billion dollar company operating
globally
the two primary markets that we sell to
large buyers in i mean certainly the u.s
china but also western europe um
by operating in those three geographies
we certainly get a vantage point into a
number of different
environmental and sustainability
requirements from an rfp perspective and
that helps shape what we target our
products and solutions at as far as
delivering to our customer requirements
as well as supporting our corporate
sustainability goals
okay thank you yamas
uh thank you very much senator thank you
all for coming and before i start i just
want to say thank you also to brendan uh
for doing a great job over the summer at
office depot
uh
clearly the school of forestry
environmental studies creates
good it's leaders good students um he
did a great job for us
with that so office depot as you may
know is one of the world's largest
resellers of office products now with
our partnership on recent merger with
officemax we're an even larger uh
provider of um office products we own
over 60 countries
and
many people know us as primarily a
retailer because you see stores
and
people don't realize that we also have
one of the largest websites in the world
in terms of volume of transactions it's
one of the top five in the world
and
the majority of the business however is
b2b
meaning
government buyers so the federal
government is a very large buyer of
office products and technology and
furniture from from office depot now the
merged office max states are large
buyers university systems hospitals
school districts
and
um
you know the the the purpose of the
session is to discuss that channel of
bio that segment of the of the buying
marketplace and as anastasia alluded to
it's historically the marketplace that's
been
thought about less in terms of
sustainability
if you look at the history of the
sustainability movement and
in the early 90s there was a lot of
focus on the green consumer and how we
can move the green consumer i would
characterize the current current
thinking still
elevates the consumer as the target
for us to focus on
in terms of driving behavior change
i'd say that's misplaced focus
and it is the big buyer
in the fed in federal governments and
countries and states in hospitals and
hotel chains
in companies around the world that will
really
uh make the big difference in terms of
accelerating our our transition to
sustainability and uh hope we can have a
good conversation about that topic today
great so i think we get the context now
and one of the challenges in the
sustainability field as you're all i'm
sure aware is all of the different
competing definitions of what's a green
product what is a sustainable product
who gets to define that and between your
two organizations or
say you're representing retailers and
suppliers at a higher level
um
how do you come together to create
similar definitions is there ever
conflict between the two positions to
how much who is leading whom
in that relationship
you want to start my sure yeah it's a
dialogue so i mean yamas and i we share
the same customer base i mean maybe a
little bit different geographic or
global scale but uh and and we share
that belief a lot of the forums that we
operate in i mean the consumer has not
been the driver of sustainable
transition i mean you know follow the
money follow the spin uh that large
institutional buyer or retailer as
regulator maybe as a terminology or
retailer as a driver of
spend i mean have
been a change driver in sustainability
space
but to your question around you know
where there is competition or conflict
um
you know i firmly believe that industry
has the ability to drive change in the
product sets
beyond the capability of government
regulation
that seems to be kind of the last
generation driver of change i mean
regulating to better
our customers are starting to demand
that as they see the strategic benefit
of their purchases i mean
15 years ago we were having a discussion
really with the cto
the cto was making purchases based on
lowering the cost of his i.t spend
that i.t spin though was not taking into
context the energy footprint acros that
the cfo was having to bear
so inside our target customers some of
that conflict was i'm trying to lower my
energy costs i'm trying to lower my i.t
spend the two are going in different
directions
through a lens of sustainability
we're able to have that collective
discussion with the cfo and the cto and
drive the right outcome to get lower
lower cost of i.t spend and lower longer
term energy costs
for these companies and in turn
many times support you know carbon goals
within the company that we're servicing
as well as our own goals
um
there certainly are i mean to be
effective in driving sustainability
purchasing requirements i mean i believe
it has to involve a multi-stakeholder
engagement really there are kind of four
primary stakeholders at that i mean
industry government non-governmental
organizations and academia
um
there there are forums where the emotive
topics still live
as a driver of change as opposed to the
scientifically based topics
trying to get that science on the table
to drive better outcomes is where we're
working in the forums that we're engaged
in globally
and that conflict many times is the
emotive versus scientific but young as
you've got a lot of other forms that you
see things through i'm curious about
your perspective
and so my perspective starts with the
um the question of who's leading whom
and i think the answer is really
like many good answers is it depends
and
and certainly in some cases government
is leading so for the the
ep tool that we'll talk about the
environment the electronic product
environmental assessment tool is
something that that both uh michael and
i are very familiar with you you might
not be at the moment it's a it's a
multi-attribute definition of green
electronic
green electronic product and it was
developed
in partnership with epa
industry ngos
uh including
ngos like silicon valley silicon
valley take back coalition is that the
one time
a multi-stakeholder group of actors said
there is no definition of green green
technology let's create one together but
it was really the government that
created the impetus for that
multi-stakeholder effort to to be um
to to develop because they wanted to
focus on technology and they wanted to
find it so they could buy it
um so they're government-led in other in
other categories there really is no
definition or there's multiple
definitions so
ask anyone in this room what is the
definition of green paper
and
we'll get potentially very different
perspectives we're in the school of
forestry some people would say that
not using recycled content is good
because it helps retain forests as
productive assets others would say you
know 30 recycled content is the
appropriate
value that's the federal requirement
others would say 100 recycled is
appropriate and then that's ignoring the
whole forest certification debate around
sfi and fsc
um that's also very uncertain so there
is multiple definitions therefore a lack
of a definition of green paper
and and that
even that is just part of the question
because
sustainability is not just green
what about the social dimensions of of
the purchase or the economic dimensions
of the purchase how do you pack that in
so i
expressed all of that because i wanted
to just illustrate that in in some
sectors in some categories there is
clear definition led by one actor in
others you need to either create your
own definition or your own approach
but ultimately it is more
multi-stakeholder efforts like like ep
and sustainable purchasing leadership
council that i think will get us from
lack of clarity
to
clarity on on what constitutes greener
more sustainable products
okay so we are um working together to
create these definitions through these
different standards and um
multi-stakeholder initiatives and so
forth so as a company going into those
processes
do you have a kind of a clear
commercial agenda in helping setting
standards or creating standards through
a standard setting process or is it
more you know let's see how it goes
let's try to shape this together how
open is that process
sure
um
like yamaha's answer it depends on what
the forum is targeting okay
you know with respect to epeate we
entered into it was kind of uh
greenfield
so we entered into that certainly to get
to a baseline standard
as that matured and was adopted by
institutional purchasers
we saw the evolution of retailers
starting to target
green buying requirements
the sustainability consortium was a
concept that was pulled together by
walmart a couple of other name large
retailers in academia we had a more
targeted purpose in being involved with
the tsc we felt like our industry had uh
progressed purchasing requirements for
electronics and by the way 95 of us
federal spend must be against the ep
standard so it's not a small amount of
spend we're talking about but in
entering into the tsc we really were
trying to assure that we didn't
diverge from the good work that our
sector had done
so a lot of the purpose was to try to
assure that we leveraged epeed
recognizing that ep wasn't perfect and
it needed some better scientific basis
on a number of the criteria
so trying to target our spend within the
tsc
to point it at criteria that needed
better scientific basis and then also
keep in both of those the opportunity to
raise the bar for everyone as a
mandatory set of requirements and then
provide market incentives through
optional criteria that we could then
continue to move the needle
by tipping the supply chain so i mean
those two
represent different approaches that we
have
okay
so if we look at the current landscape
in many product categories
because there is lack of clarity on the
core definition of
greenness or sustainability in in uh in
that category
we think there is
um it's important for commercial
entities who understand their product
categories to participate in the
development process of the definition
and to help the marketplace the the
diverse marketplace understand that it
is that is putting forward inconsistent
market signals that disallow suppliers
like hers and dell and others
to
scale
in the right ways
so for example we have to have multiple
products with multiple environmental or
social attributes to serve multiple
segments all of whom are trying to buy
sustainably
all of them and there's just a very
different signal whether it's the state
of washington or the federal government
or the city of portland or yale
you're giving us different signals
and so if we can if we can help um
as a recipient of that
lack of clear signal if we can
contribute
and help
sort of coalesce this
this diversity into greater clarity i
think that um that will help overall in
terms of
the advancement of sustainability and
then yes of course as you participate in
this and contribute your thought
leadership in your time then you're
you're differentiating yourselves as a
participant
rather than a status quo or external to
that to that dialogue
so right now you are communicating
different sustainability attributes of
your products
to different
purchases if you like or to different
customers
does that vary a lot by say can you
cluster them in terms of government
commercial universities hospitals um
are they aligned at least within
each of those buckets or are they really
all over the map all over the map okay
and every i mean so maybe
we've chosen not to advance our own
rating system some of our competitors
have done that in the past i mean we've
tended to adopt you know ep or the
regional requirement for selling to the
federal government in china there's the
china environmental certification
um
yeah so in some ways we've been forced
to because
we can rely on ep and energy staff for
technology but what about pens
what about when a customer again like
yale or boston university asks us how
many green products do you have
how do you answer that
whose definition your screen building
council's definition state of washington
definition the federal government's
definition our definition what's the
right answer and then and then how do
you report
um
spend against
those green or sustainable products
because if you're asking for the
definition you want you want to track
so we've got multiple different
reporting types
um we've got a report for
for people pursuing lead we've got a
report for the federal government we've
got a report for aishi who does the star
system that has a definition of green
paper so we've got maybe you know 15 20
different custom reports to describe
sustainable purchasing or green perch
great regis green purchasing for
multiple different different segments
and um and then you have a catalog that
you've combined all of this together in
do you want to just describe the three
pieces of green
the way that you
try to simplify this message
so we
we have developed our own approach or a
definition for for greener
products greener office products um
and
the the system that
anastasia is describing in terms of
three three levels
um we develop basically by
reading the environmentally preferable
purchasing policies
of about 30 different institutional
buying
segments
so
we looked at we read the purchasing
policy for the state of washington
and for the u.s green building council
the guidance they give for sustainable
purchasing
and 30 others state of california state
of florida minnesota city of portland
city seattle city city san francisco
et cetera so 30 of these policies and we
sort of mapped out what are people
asking for what are the attributes and
the eco labels and the specifications
that different institutional buyers are
seeking
and just to use papers as an as an
example
um
and to some degree repeat uh what i said
in a couple of minutes ago the state of
washington had a 100 recycled
uh mandate the governor the governor of
the state of washington has said state
agencies in washington must buy 100 per
consumer recycled paper
in the federal government it was 30
recycled paper
in um the u.s green building council
guidance it was fsc certified
and um
when wirehouser buys paper they want it
to be sfi certified
so what we decided is rather than
rather than take a position say you know
that one is right and all the rest are
wrong
we said let's reflect back in our system
what the marketplace is signaling to us
and so we designated
the dark green to the state of
washington
uh definitions 100 recycled paper would
be dark green in our system 30 recycle
would be mid green that means a federal
standard fsc certified would be light
green
uh and then sfi would be meets industry
environmental norms that's a that's a
politically sensitive way to address
that nuance
and
and then we did the same rating system
for
every product category we sell so we
rely on we we rely on ep and energy star
for technology we rely on level and
green guard and other eco labels for
furniture and and where there are no eco
labels we use attributes as that
delineation
so so maybe to further on that i mean
respect to different approaches i mean
so creating your own buying standard
we've tended to stay with the
governmental-led or
multi-stakeholder lead buying criteria
we've seen a number of there's i think
are 45 different ict eco labels globally
with a whole bunch of other
environmental labels wrapped around them
you know cec and china ep in the us it
now goes to 41 countries in in europe
you've got tco and blue angel i mean
what we've really been working toward
you know this is kind of the holy grail
of standards and regulations as you know
global harmonization that's probably not
never going to happen however we've
worked
globally to educate our sales team
especially in the public sector to
sell as equal or better for rfp
proposals with epeat
and then work to drive memorandums of
understanding between those purchasing
entities within europe and china
to try to adopt those mutually
and we're having some success at that
and the reason for that and you've said
it specifically is scale and the
commoditization of ict
i mean it's a global product that we're
building in a few locations in the world
what we deliver to our commercial
customers benefits consumers also uh we
don't see the attributes that consumers
want being significantly different and
to give you a specific example of how we
leverage those two things together uh
within ap they're you know 44 to 51
different criteria
e-waste and take-back certainly is one
aspect of that we offer take-back
services as a commercial service for our
commercial customers
that requires us to manage primarily the
data i mean that's what customers care
most about when their ict comes back and
then they want to make sure that it goes
into a responsible take back stream
there are 195 waste streams from a
computer
we manage and govern those so that we
can assure that data is maintained and
secure and that value is extracted from
that end of life resource whether it's
reuse or repurposing or parts are being
used
we've leveraged that because we need to
do that globally
to offer free consumer take to take back
globally also
we would not have led with free consumer
take back though had we not had a global
need for b2b services so that
trickle-down effect
in the consumer is very beneficial but
we then also try to drive for that uh
common criteria set in those global
regulations or standards so
the ability to make those work together
we found be very very beneficial from a
scale perspective
uh are any of these large buyers just
saying just
i want the green box i want to tip the
green box
keep it simple
please just
do what you got to do to figure this out
for us
and in that
scenario do you have any ability to tell
a story that's a little more interesting
that is sort of more motivating to them
to buy your product instead of another
one
if they just want simplicity
does that then negate the ability to
talk about some of the more interesting
take back programs or other attributes
that you're you've invested a lot in
because you think there is a market
power there
well i'd say the
the customer is not homogeneous yep and
so yes there are
yes there are some that have no interest
whatsoever and you start the
conversation about sustainability and
they're just you know their their eyes
glaze over and they're just not
interested
and then there are others where there's
a policy requirement and so
they're almost forced from a policy
standpoint to do the de minimis amount
of work that they could do to tick the
box um
but then there's you know then there's
there's those who are genuinely
interested and want to
through
passion um or or personal interest
they're uh
they're doing they're making their
purchasing decisions they're making
making them you know differently
so you almost have layered amounts of
information
yeah so if people ask me when i was a
phd student what's your phd on i'd sort
of give them the you know the one minute
version see if they're interested five
minute version i didn't want to keep the
hour-long version
really interesting there's people who
are not asking you well that's true
indeed so you don't you don't
necessarily when they're not asking you
don't necessarily impose
you know your entire dissertation on
them in a cocktail party because it will
turn them off you might have done this
some of you but
but it's not a way to engage them so
you've got to find what you've got to
find what interests them and uh
and through that
layer in your
so for the ones who are not interested
is there a way of choice editing for
them so that they really actually only
see the greener option
and don't even see the rest
so dell's business model historically
had been configured to order
or built to order i mean customized
electronics for you know whatever you
build your system
that is not our business model and we've
shifted in the last two years i mean it
is much more a built to order model
where we're building for the the channel
the supply chain
in that former model um it was a little
more complex the ability to you know de
facto deliver green which by the way in
most rfqs that we have i mean it green
is not the buying decision maker i mean
it's typically bonus points
it might be a tiebreaker on some
occasions we'll see in rfps there is
actually
an award of the points you know the
greatest we've seen i think is about a
30 on one major bid in france in the
last year
um
but we we have the ability through this
build to order model now with a much
narrower catalog
back to scale
we're able to deliver many more
environmental attributes because it's in
the benefit of our supply chain
reducing complexity in the offers
you know a lot of this were talking to
the context of rfps but you do have some
customers back you know what is the
definition of sustainability it means
different things to different folks some
purchasers do go above and beyond the
rfp requirement of say ep they may have
a keen interest in your social supply
chain
they may be looking at carbon reduction
in their
for their customers or within their
business
the good news is you're having that
dialogue with those companies
and that
construct allows a framework for you to
do it okay
so one one mechanism to
choice edit is to remove choice of the
non-non-green or non-sustainable
products
and
that i would characterize as a draconian
way to
pursue
environmental purchasing or to encourage
environmental
purchasing and there are degrees of
draconianism
from that which is no
you basically you've gotta you gotta buy
the
you gotta buy the greener greener
product and and an example of how we do
that is when a customer asks us for a
forced substitution
uh we we will and
officemax does this as well legacy
office max so they buy and this is not a
good perfect example but they you know
they're about to buy the
the disposable and then we we send
the
the non-dispersal i mean
we don't use it we don't do it for these
types of products but we do it for paper
so they buy a virgin paper the system
has has um
logic that says they purchased the
non-certified or sfi certified product
the system will send the 30 recycled fsc
that
is an example of things we we do and
have done
in many uh in many companies now
the end user is sometimes surprised at
that if communication hasn't worked you
know
the communication hasn't hasn't
been been sent effectively
they sometimes send those products back
because they think the wrong product
arrived they hadn't ordered that thing
so communication is very important in in
that the other less draconian method is
the nudge where they're about to buy x
the system will say hey you're about to
buy x there is a environmentally
preferable alternative available here's
the price here are the specs do you like
it
opt-in by that
and so that system
is less draconian and more and do people
take you up on that they do a lot of
people think it's up on that yamas does
that typically come at a price
no it's so prosperity it depends on the
product category
and
there's a
if any of you become
market research folks
in
in environmental sustainability please
promise me you will not ask this
question
how much more would you be willing to
pay for a green product
please
it is the stock question
in
environmentally themed market research
and it's
completely
erroneous as a question because
there is a whole range of economic
consequences of more environmental
sustainable choices
one consequence is lower cost
so
remanufactured products refurbished
furniture and technology um
tap water instead of bottled water
a whole range of product categories
where the in more environmentally
sustainable choice is
less expensive right away
then there's the
higher initial cost lower operating cost
examples and so leds the lights you have
in this building the building itself
maybe higher initial cost but lower
operating cost
and potentially very significant cost
savings within three six nine months
twelve twelve month payback periods so
again economically beneficial
save um higher initial costs lower
repurchase cost
because you're buying this once might
cost ten dollars but you're not buying a
hundred of these at fifty dollars
so there are those three saves of green
i call save initial cost save operating
cost savoury purchase cost that really
should be factored into this this this
um
this decision this approach so not
always in different categories
it really depends what the cost
consequences
i'm going to hand it over to the
audience for questions and while you
think of your questions uh i'll ask one
more um and when you have a question if
you can use the microphone so that it
comes through um on the recording and
say your name and
affiliation to the school or otherwise
so um
i just wondered like how
how much transparency do you really want
to give on all of the many many many
complicated environmental social
economic aspects of your products and
services obviously for yamas at office
depot you have so many product lines i
don't know how many skus you want to
enlighten us that you guys sell 300 000
okay so can you imagine 300 000 times i
don't know how however many attributes
um of those particular products three
hundred we have we've done three hundred
thousand a hundred thousand dollar lcas
on all of those products
really no no we haven't
didn't come to my company
we would not be in business if we did an
lca on every one of our 300 products
so i mean going to lca and the
complexity of some of this information
so how transparent are you
do you draw a line somewhere if you are
not certain about the data in some
capacity or you're not exactly you
haven't checked it to the nth degree do
you just leave that part of it out of
the story do you say you know how much
do people really need to know and want
to know about
i think the word you used initially is
what you have to do which is be
transparent about what you're not
including okay um and then and that's
the approach we've taken so be
transparent about what you're not
including and obviously yeah i mean data
fidelity and availability of data these
i mean now i mean there's a demand for
it i mean we've we've just rolled out
our csr 2020 goals we've shifted the
time frame for dell's corporate
responsibility goals
we've been reporting csr for the last
11 years now i mean it's been an
annual report
fairly transparent with those goals and
the annual
delivery on those
there were aspects over the 11-year
period where
we didn't know what we didn't know we
didn't know we needed to go in that
space that wasn't for transparency just
you know we're learning it's a journey
and we're making progress but when you
shift to a longer range as we have this
year to you know eight year time horizon
uh we we see to be very transparent we
have 21 goals um i think about 18 of
them are fairly well defined with
metrics and kpis there are a couple that
we still need to develop the uh the
metrics to undergird and communicate
transparently we're open about that fact
but we believe you know part of changing
that time horizon is i mean as we've
seen in the last 10 years consumers
commercial customers want more
information about the product they're
buying and the availability is
increasing we think in the next eight
years that's going to increase
significantly you've got to be
transparent about all the things that
you're doing and you'll actually see
that in most of the goals that we have
is i mean one the overarching
transparency goal but
each of them were reporting against them
and that's demanded
so we're transparent from very
transparent from an operation standpoint
so carbon water
waste and
availability of products with
environmental attributes and sales of
products and environmental attributes we
do we do a lot of operational level
transparency then at the product level
we
really focus on attributes and eco
labels that are sought by customer by
our b2b customers
so we will
transparently disclose and encourage our
suppliers to to track and provide and
sign affidavits around the environmental
claims they're making about the product
whether they're
um low toxicity
eco labels or recycle attributes or the
whole range of
you know 20 or 30 attributes and 400 eco
labels so that we're very we're probably
done more work than than than than most
companies to disclose
uh whether an item that is being
purchased has this attribute or eco
label or or not
what we're less um
able to do as a reseller is provide
embedded impact
data so the embedded we have had
customers ask for the embedded impact of
all those all the pens they're buying
and the the the life cycle plastic
associated with this and the life cycle
energy
now
maybe
in 50 years time that
will be mandated or viable
um
but i think it we're a long way off
being able to
ourselves or any other company
to truly provide embedded impact
information and i think we should be
more focused and that might not even be
the right thing to do because the amount
of effort involved in calculating those
sorts of things accurately for for small
value low value products i think
industry average
or aggregate level information is really
where we should be putting our focus so
we're we're a buyer
like yale or someone else is buying
twenty thousand pens and
fifty thousand rooms of paper and
uh spending two million dollars on food
and five million dollars on electricity
i think we should focus our efforts
around life cycle understanding and
impact uh at that level that scale
so we can focus our efforts
when we purchase
to the product categories that have
highest embedded impact at the aggregate
level
and once you understand that you can say
okay because of that we're going to put
our attention in terms of the way we're
going to buy
to those product categories first and
we're going to we're going to transition
spending
towards
items in that product category that have
lower embedded impact and we obviously
need to work out what those are but that
that
you can work that out by determining the
attributes
of attributes or recall labels that
represent lower embedded impact and
that's that's certainly the direction
we're going in
in sustainable purchasing leadership
council
we think there hasn't been enough focus
at at that macro scale and perhaps
too much focus
on um
on the micro scale and maybe we're
missing what matters most
because we're focused on the micro
and that's
that's okay i have a question at the
back please
hi i'm susannah harris i'm a first-year
student at the school of forestry and
environmental studies
i have a question yamas about the
communications that accompany the system
by which you send one of your customers
a more environmentally friendly product
than the one they ordered
and i just hope to go into a little bit
more detail about when that
communication happens through what
medium and what messages
when you say when you say the system you
mean the online system or just in
general how we communicate this the
nudge you mentioned um there is one
system by which you actually send
customers a different product than the
one they ordered and one that's more
environmentally friendly yeah if i if i
understood you correctly and i was
wondering
you said that there's some
communications that go along with that
where sometimes the customer doesn't
understand that this is really the
product they were supposed to receive
right maybe there's a miscommunication
associated with that i was just curious
to hear a little bit more detail about
that process and why you do that sure
okay so let's say there's a purchaser
who has an environmentally prepared
purchasing policy and would like
the institution to buy let's use that
use that example this is a real example
uh buy 30 recycled paper as a policy
so that that purchasing director will
work with you know the office depot
sales person or in this example you know
office max sales person and would say
hey let's do a four substitution so if
anyone if anyone buys or puts in their
cart one of these 50 products
default
the ordering
to the other product that we've agreed
so quietly we agree over here and then
the greener product is sent
so
that can happen automatically
and
in some cases the you know the person
just accepts that that is the case it
might have been a mistake but they'll
just take that product but the best way
to do that for substitution is by
communicating uh actually the best way
to do it is in in a multi-step process
firstly engage the people
who
do the buying
in
the rationale for the institution to be
making these policy changes
and
include them in the decision making
process and then um then they're mooring
then communicate when this is going to
happen
um it's been done where there's no
communication and you get confusion and
returns and it's been done where there
is communication and enrollment and that
is more successful
rafi taherian yell dining
you both indicated earlier that
your
largest customer or one of the biggest
customers the federal government
or government agencies
and and the key stakeholders in terms of
driving your sustainability initiative
i'm uh wondering how do you see
um
regulatory
involvement of the government
in the area of this sustainability
rather than just
a
customer
driven and applied to your companies
so
whether you prefer
them to be a customer that is making a
certain criteria for you
or
whether you prefer them to be involved
in a regulatory
position
creating a level field between you and
your competitors
classical
clarifying question do you mean at the
regulation around the production
of the products or regulation around the
purchase and thresholds for purchasing
ultimate service delivery
so
in your case you're a retailer
and so and in dell cases the
manufacturers but ultimately you both
deliver a product to your uh customer
base
i think we're like the third largest
electronics retailer online also so we
have a retail presence also but
they need to play in both spaces and and
we encourage that i mean you got to put
your money where your mouth is from a
standpoint if you want the requirement
you need to buy the requirements i mean
the u.s
you know omb mandate that 95 of the
federal spend must be against the ep
standard i mean it's what made the ep
requirement real had it not been for
that
there would not have been nearly as much
effort in developing that requirement
and it probably would have never gotten
off the ground
but we also wanted
i mean
epa and a number doe a number of other
entities at the table to help shape
those responsible standards
part of it is also educational we
believe that we know our technology
space better than government better than
government globally we know we do
we know how to drive efficiency and
effectiveness in that space
so we want to have the ability in
partnership you know substantiated by
academia and the science but also
non-governmental organizations that are
looking at you know longer-range
strategies and impacts but uh but back
to the question i think you need at the
purchasing level and also at the
regulation
what is effective and we're seeing this
globally a lot are technical barriers to
trade that are being instituted
on the environmental space but also on
other product compliance requirements
that's a challenge and
getting those harmonized so that
free markets can exist i mean is an
effective means of
in raising you know the bar or leveling
the playing field
on the innovation side though
probably less regulation
we don't afford innovation within
companies to deliver
um what makes us better than our
competitors
can ask them about the regulation and
the omb the 95 requirement is that
is that a regulation
so the federal acquisition regulation
specifies which governs purchasers in
the u.s
yeah the far the federal acquisition
regulation i mean i can't remember the
paragraph but uh
1.1 but it tells you that you have to
purchase
that 95 omb
governs that so every purchaser in the
government i mean they're looking at a
scorecard annually to see that ict spend
to assure that it's purchased against 95
there are exceptions so there's why five
percent not a hundred there are special
requirements within the government that
uh maybe don't allow us to uh redundancy
and i mean anyway but then there's an
executive order executive order 13514
obama put out in 2009 which also has a
95 percent sustainable
requirement but i that's not a far that
is a optional
direction for for agencies to to buy
against it's not embedded in the far
yeah that's what makes ieee 1680 ep very
unique
that it's embedded in the law for
government to purchase it's in the far
which is the effect of purchasing law
but then there's another layer of
regulation which is for example ross the
restriction on hazardous substances that
dell and others have to
really
because you use um put forward ross as a
as a mandate you're essentially forced
to pursue ross
with the ross regulation based on for
global manufacturing on you is that is
that a default now um it's not a default
for everyone i mean when ross was
initially promulgated i mean certainly
that was our strategic choice i mean
commoditized electronics global scale
deliver ross there's not a first world
and third world product we're not gonna
you know if you don't have a law we're
gonna put lead in your country if you
know it it's regulated under ross that
was our choice there are some companies
that do you have a lot of white box
manufacturers in various countries that
still are using
lead that said though when you have the
key players you know dell hp apple that
have committed to delivering ros
compliant products the supply chain has
to convert over and the supply chain did
convert over in the ross conversion it
was more than just lead
um
i'm still kind of you know amused
sometimes when we're looking for a
localized product and we get feedback
from a supplier that well you can get it
cheaper if it's lead when you really dig
into that it turns out you can't even
really find the lead-based products so
but there are some folks that are
delivering non-ross compliant products
and geographies that allow that or
it's a different uh playing field as a
multinational corporation than sometimes
the local uh suppliers
you have a question over here
i'm sorry
yeah
hi um i'm no affiliation with the
university as of now i'm a prospective
fps student
um my question is i guess it's a mess in
my head so i'm going to try to
um
i'm kind of interested if
you're either of your two industries or
businesses have a commitment towards a
more sustainable world from a purchaser
and retailer perspective
by
i know
office depot you said you do a lot of
assessments on the government state city
or industry purchasing let's say um
x organization or x industry is looking
to purchase something but their policy
mandates
one level of sustainable products or
green products
is there any
push from a sales perspective i under
you you kind of tapped into how much
more would you spend for a greener
product but is there any push towards
large scale purchasers like hospitals or
government organizations
towards saying uh you know you're
purchasing this and at this amount
do you guys feel any pressure or
commitment towards creating more
sustainable world by just
enforcing that or
don't you
so i think it's a pretty good uh lead
into the framework for the splc i mean
the sustainable purchasing leadership
council i mean we you see in some
sectors where there's you know a eco
label
you know that's what we call them um
specific to the sector i mean many of
these large purchasers i mean are buying
you know hundreds of product categories
um
you know as a corporate commitment for
dell i mean our one of our values and
strategies is enabling our consumers
customers
the power to do more
we believe part of that certainly are
the environmental attributes of our
products uh where you see that manifest
itself though are in influencing these
eco labels so that they are more
responsible especially when they are
requirements of purchasing and then
we're looking at that more broadly in
the splc from the electronics
perspective it's much broader than that
so if i interpret your question i think
what you're saying is how much do we try
and
push our customer base to adopt these
more sustainable products and how much
do we
do do that same do we not just push
externally but push ourselves internally
to buy in line with what we're selling
yeah so very much so we are um
our uh environmental strategy is
encapsulated in a in a vision to buy
greener bee greener and sell greener and
so and we measure each of those they're
not just words there's there's
measurement of how much we're buying
greener measurement of
how we're being greener in terms of
carbon waste and water and how we're
selling greenish i'll tell you in in
2005 we had about 1.2 billion dollars
worth of
sale product sales with some
environmental attribute
and in 2012 it was 1.98 billion so
a
you know
nearly 800 million dollar growth in
sales of products with environmental
attributes based on based on our
definition
and that's really come
through engaging large institutional
buyers over the last number of years to
to make shifts in purchasing patents
we have a question over here
adrian horton i'm an alumni alumnus of
school of forest environmental science
the conversation so far has been focused
a lot on
outside the consumers enterprise buyers
governments i'm just curious
what happens inside your large
organizations how did the conversation
on sustainability evolved uh over the
last i don't know five to ten years
and how did that change your day-to-day
jobs in terms of who you talk to who you
meet how your initiatives approved sort
of give us a little bit of the of the
internal landscape and what's happening
inside
thank you
okay i'll uh i'll make sure i lean in um
yeah over the last five or ten years
i mean
sustainability is a journey and i mean
it's important that it be recognized at
the top but grassroots led by the folks
that actually do the work inside the
company
we've done a i believe a fairly good job
over the last five years of
connecting those two i'd say 10 years
ago i was maybe a little bit of a gap
between those things
but how that works internally at dell
i'm not our executive director of
sustainability i mean i actually would
like to see all sustainability roles
eliminated because they actually are
embedded in the business
i'm part of our r d organization
so we're very focused on
aligning our csr goals to business
leaders
and embedding those in the performance
of those business leaders not because i
mean only it's the good or right thing
to do but because provides return for
that business
but we do have still
a very small team of sustainability
strategists
we actually have a sustainability
operating council which is
membership is by each one of those
relevant businesses that have goals that
are important for our csr report
and dell's
latest restructuring there really are
four primary leaders of the business
beyond michael dell
each one of those four business leaders
they're known as the elt the executive
leadership team each one of them has
ownership of individual goals some were
specific to them and some are broader
reaching our people and community goals
but that sustainability operating
council defines those metrics and kpis
they are vetted with the business owned
by the business and they are reviewed
with the elt on a quarterly basis
really on an annual basis from a
re-measure perspective
but
and michael dell personally sees those
sustainability commitments and goals um
that's
didn't quite work that way 10 years ago
so it's it's an evolution and a lot of
that is because it matters to our
customers and our purchasers and we're
making those transparent external
commitments
that our brand you know
reflects or will be reflected upon if we
don't deliver on them
so i'd say that brief and one more
question
sure um dell has a pretty robust
governance structure for for
sustainability as do perhaps a handful
of other fortune 500 companies out of
the 500
in my in my you know assessment of lots
of
sustainability reports
i i doubt there's more than 20 or 30
companies that have a robust
ceo led or senior executive-led
governance council maybe maybe 30
maximum so we're an example of that we
really have um
we're sorry when i say we're an example
for example we don't have a very
well-defined governance structure with
the ceo and the stakeholder committee
finding kpis what we have at office
depot is a small team of uh
environmental strategy folks who's
whose role is to nudge the organization
in a greener direction internally
and we do that by in with three main
tools we we initiate
programs
we integrate ideas and encourage
ownership of those programs and we
communicate success
um
so
making the business case to a functional
leader as to why
investing in you know energy efficiency
is good
um educating
people
running programs that did result in
business value
that we then communicate and
internally seen as a good thing
therefore it needs to be repeated
uh it's a very uh it's a new role in
corporate america that
um
in some way is being defined by the
people who are doing it right now that
makes it very exciting but it also makes
it very confusing in some respects
because you don't know necessarily who
should who should have decision
authority who whose budget should pay
for program x where does it where did
the benefits accrue how do the benefits
get shared
our cfo said this function is in the
second innings
and i think it's a very useful useful
thing to say to me because it puts it in
a much longer arc so you don't need to
get
all of you who are going to these
functions going these roles are going to
want to do everything tomorrow
you're going to try and do the nine
innings in nine minutes
because you've got a passion for this
space
but
we are in the second innings
and so if we if we have a long time
horizon for our achieving our objectives
i i think strategic strategic having
strategic patience
is helpful in
in in moving the needle within within a
company i have one more question and
then i'm afraid we have to wrap up
thank you so much um i'm yoni i'm from
the school of management um i think i'm
with rafi
on uh the the regulatory interest
you know the title of this is nudging
big business it seems like a really
compelling way to nudge
business towards environmental practices
to regulate them i'm wondering
you know seeing as this is sort of a
commons issue if you get to play in that
sort of commons agreement space at all
it seems like you could play a really
important role in helping to bring about
new visionary policy
and if you aren't working with
regulators and policy makers
why not
do you work with the
with the government to push new policy
so it's i'd characterize splc
sustainable purchasing leadership
council is an example of of exactly that
so
this effort
originated in a
um
in a
you know conversation that started about
an eco-labeling bill in 2007 and 8 where
senator dianne feinstein
considered putting an eco-labeling bill
to regulate this space regulate the
green market market space as a
regulatory program as a federal federal
program
and over the over the years it evolved
in a way that
has led to a multi-stakeholder
collaboration with suppliers and buyers
and ngos and government all
together
defining
what the market space should look like
and yes there'll be you know potentially
regulation as part of that regulation
around green chemistry regulation around
energy efficiency et cetera but
it's really i think our involvement in
in that broader
broader solution is i would characterize
the right way to go and i'll close with
an analogy
there is a building code
and that exists and there's also lead
perhaps we can have
in the sustainable pushing space the
same
layering where there's
regulatory code
around purchasing
standards as a baseline that everyone
can
uh align towards and then there's a
scale
of practice that has been defined in a
collaborative manner
in a way that suppliers and resellers
and buyers can all
um
uh
appreciate and implement against
and and within that there's layering
of of uh ability
michael any final thoughts
i mean i i think you're uh strategically
disadvantaged if you're not engaged at
the table with regulators on shaping
responsible um criteria i mean 20 years
ago we were at the table helping shape
energy star
we were there one because there was a
lack of energy efficiency in the
electronic space but but also on more
strategic basis
we wanted energy star to be the
cornerstone of our development strategy
globally and we've been fairly effective
the u.s has been fairly progressive on
the energy requirements europe maybe
more so on the materials but kind of to
pick up on you know the second inning i
mean you look around globally a lot of
the key markets a lot of these countries
haven't even started the game yet
and we're i mean able to
position
u.s or most responsible global standards
or regulations
to help jump-start that and then
leverage it for in our case what we have
as a global product so that we can be
more competitive globally
so with that
and be more than glad to talk more
afterward
okay well thank you everyone we're a
little overtime so i'm going to close
this session i want to thank very much
our two speakers for coming out here
joining us and sharing all their words
of wisdom and thoughts on this topic
thank you very much
the next uh speaking um
event in this series is on january 30th
uh it's with new belgium brewing a beer
company
so from a very different different
industry different kind of challenges um
certainly very tasty ones so that should
be fun
and for more information on this series
you can go to the yale.edu
cb ey see bay
website um there's more information
there and thank you all goodbye